Mark Landsman, Filmmaker of SCANDALOUS: The Untold Story of the National Enquirer:
...And that's not to say that like I was
born to make a story about a supermarket
tabloid. Like I never read The Enquirer
growing up, I never cared about
supermarket tabloids. I thought it was a
joke.
Film Courage: I was listening to an interview with
John Pilger he's a journalist and
someone in the audience yelled out at a
Q& A "There's this issue..."
and went on and on "What are you doing
about it." Because he covers various
issues in his films and he said [Paraphrasing] "Well why
do I have to be the poster child of
having to do something about it. We can
all do something about it nowadays." how
do you feel about that because it used
to be a select group that would be able
to spotlight these stories and go and
delve in and now all of that's anyone
any one sort of with their own agenda or
their own need to tell a story and a
camera or a phone can do that what are
your thoughts I think I think ultimately
what I'm what I'm getting from the
question is it's kind of a larger a
larger issue about like the ability to
get stories out there right I mean we
all have Twitter right Twitter's a
storytelling device in X number of
characters or less all of these devices
all of these apps are newfangled stories
and we're all kind of technically our
own little filmmaker I don't think
that's the same as making a film there's
a responsibility in making a film if
you're making a film about something
that's true if you're making a film
about something that's about real life
or if you're even making a scripted film
about something that's historical
fiction you know you have a
responsibility as the filmmakers to do
justice to that story otherwise you're
going to slip into the propaganda
universe and just be filling the world
with more of that and I think filmmakers
are bold and they're on the frontier
they're truth seekers I think that's
true of even the best scripted
filmmakers you know I mean I think back
to BOYS DON'T CRY you know and what
Kimberly Peirce did you know that was an
incredibly powerful i opening experience
that the world hadn't seen before
and she did tremendous justice to that i
think we you know that's i like that
your site is called Film Courage because
that's the kind of courage
that that it takes to be a filmmaker you
have to be willing to really tell the
truth and not be sort of just agenda
pushing all day long because people see
right through that and by the way it's
you know unless you're the president in
the United States whose agenda pushing
all day long you know you're you know
you're most likely kind of in your own
little echo chamber and you have to be
prepared to take the punches that are
going to come yeah
online or in written form from people
that have various agendas whether they
really didn't like the film or they're
paid troll which is something that I
guess it's been around for ages but now
we have a real name for it yeah and yeah
there's just all sorts of people in the
peanut gallery that have an opinion yeah
yeah I mean the thing that's so great
about filmmaking period right now is we
all have access to these tools that we
didn't have before you know you can have
a phenomenal camera in your hand you can
have a phenomenal editing device on your
laptop you know when I started out it's
like you can do that no you had to go
and you know wait by the a/v cage and
your high school or your college and
hope you got a camera then you have to
take a camera out get to put film in the
camera
when I started you know what I mean and
then you know and then you know film
became these tapes that we lugged around
I mean we have you know kids can make
films these days so it's an incredible
time to be a filmmaker now it's the
question really is a kiss so what are
you gonna make a film about when you
feel that someone's got to make a film
about this story why do you feel you
need to answer the call I think it's a
very personal thing it's very subjective
for me I'm I'll be listening to public
radio for example or I'll be reading an
article and I'll get a feeling I'll get
a hit um sometimes that it'll be outrage
sometimes it'll be compassion sadness
humor it'll hit me on an emotional level
and then I'll have a thought is this a
story that could be a film and then the
next thought is um okay so if this is a
story that could be a film this is a
story that
I should tell that I'm able to tell or
I'm interested in telling and then it
kind of just goes from there I think
that there's a lot of important
questions we have to ask ourselves you
know
a very wise friend of mine a fellow
filmmaker once said to me you know
there's there's basically three basic
questions um
why this story why now why you and you
know yes there's up those three
questions and then it kind of helps you
like it gives you a little bit of a GPS
well by the way I was it like and that's
not to say that like I was born to make
a story about a supermarket tabloid like
I never read The Enquirer growing up I
never cared about supermarket tabloids I
thought it was a joke to be honest with
you the the other sort of important
thing about documentaries is access so
this story found me in a way because a
parent of one of our dear friends was in
town and we all went out and had drinks
and he starts you know rattling off
these crazy stories about his former
life as a tabloid reporter for the
National Enquirer and I was like wow
this is unbelievable
I could listen to this guy all day long
so so I knew I had a window into that
world you know before that dinner I had
no idea I didn't know I knew anyone at
the Enquirer so I think access is a huge
part of filmmaking documentary
filmmaking is you know it's one thing to
have a great idea but I think how you
get into that idea that's a huge part of
it and that that can make your life
easier as a documentarian so leaving
that family event or that that dinner
event whatever way at what point did you
start thinking in your mind I I have to
tell this story you know I'd say about
you know we had that dinner he told us
all these crazy stories about espionage
and recording people and disguises and
like you know booking hotel rooms next
to Madonna and Sean Penn and just crazy
stuff and I thought okay this is an
incredible movie and then at the same
time Jeffrey Toobin wrote an article in
The New Yorker about the relationship
between Donald and David in
the National Enquirer and that's when it
started to percolate oh this is actually
a bigger film
you know and so that's when we I called
my friend's father and I said hey do you
think you could get other of your former
colleagues to talk on camera about their
experiences as Enquirer reporters and he
said well let me work on it and that
process took many months and some people
refused my phone calls some people slam
the phone down on us
some people said I'll consider it and
never got back some people said I'd love
to you but I have a non-disclosure
agreement and I'm not gonna violate that
because I don't want to get sued they
were scared but enough of them said why
not I'll do it I don't have a contract
anymore I don't have an NDA I don't you
know this is a story that should be told
let's do it and that's when we knew we
had a film and with all that information
with that access that's when we went to
the folks at CNN Films and said hey we
have something here and during those
many months that sort of all this was
coming together and you were getting
yeses noes maybes were you also going to
the supermarket and watching people
interact with the paper absolutely I
mean that happened before that so
starting in late 2015-2016 as the
campaign was ramping up I would have
these very bizarre sensations hitting
the supermarket line looking at the
tabloid headlines because there were
these really weird stories about you
know "Hillary Clinton going to jail she's
hooked on narcotics, she has six months
to live," apparently every week she had
six months to live and then you know all
these glowing stories about Donald
and how he's going to make America great
again and
yada yada yada and it was like this is
crazy this is the National Enquirer and
I feel like I'm looking at a political
poster in my face you know with my
cereal in line at the grocery store so I
just started to feel like this is crazy
and then you start reading reports in
other places about this kind of strange
bedfellows between the presidential campaign
and AMI and David and that's when
it all started to kind of peak enough
curiosity to make us pursue a film
you